[Music]
the way you light up a room it's amazing
oh well let's get on you how you you
look very very you know I don't men
don't say this to each other but you
look stunning oh that's it thank you
very much that with your with your
yellow skin and your red hair you look
like enough
you look like at number two pencils
you've been working with Larry King
again I mean you I mean you're pale yeah
I am very very I'm very and this is
coming from a Canadian I'm pale no no no
but you're paler than any human being
that has breath going in and out of
there tried to correct a mistake with a
whiteout how long were you on the
embalming table before you you know I
have feelings I'm a human being
now I so much to talk about you're a
traveling big show business circle I do
not as you know oh I know yeah I don't
get out a lot but the George Clooney
wedding that when were you invited I
wasn't invited but I attended oh it was
showed up
I showed up but it was spectacular you
know I mean it's 13 million dollar
wedding cash bar interesting you're not
but you rented out Italy and the
reception was just yeah
beautifully was although he sat at a
singles table I didn't understand I was
very beautiful that they had a little
bride and groom on top of the prenup I
mean every detail
bhana was there Bono was there yeah
that's right I heard about that yeah no
one wanted them there but Apple insisted
[Applause]
gorgeous gorgeous affair yeah
you